das ist wirklich erstaunlich die analyse
von skeletten die mehrere jahrtausende
alt sind versetzt forschungsteams
weltweit mittlerweile in die lage das
leben der menschen damals sehr genau zu
rekonstruieren
so jetzt auch bei den großen coup eines
britischen forschungsteams durch die
sogenannte isotopenanalyse können die
forschenden das leben der alten römer
nachvollziehen und sogar das schlimme
schicksal des römischen hafens im
fünften jahrhundert verstehen klick zum
science fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
das verfahren das verschwundene welten
wieder sichtbar machen kann nennt sich
isotopenanalyse dabei weisen fachleute
automaten verschiedener chemischer
elemente in alten skelette nach es
handelt sich um stabile isotope von
elementen wie beispielsweise sauerstoff
strontium zink schwefelwasserstoff oder
kohlenstoff mit hilfe solcher isotopen
fingerabdrücke können forschende dann
viele spannende erkenntnisse zu den
menschen von damals und ihrer
lebensweise gewinnen beispielsweise
lässt sich ziemlich genau das
rekonstruieren was damals auf dem
speiseplan gestanden haben muss das ist
möglich weil die isotopen signaturen zu
lebzeiten den menschen durch trinkwasser
und der nahrung in den körper gelangen
und sich dann zum beispiel in den zähnen
knochen und haaren ablagert
die isotopenzusammensetzung in der
biosphäre sind aber auch geprägt durch
klimatische und geologische verhältnisse
in verschiedenen regionen so erlauben
die isotopenzusammensetzung die im
skelett gewebe gespeichert sind auch
aussagen zur herkunft und mobilität der
menschen und tiere strontium
beispielsweise ist im wasser enthalten
und je nach gegend enthält es
unterschiedliche isotope die sich in
haren und fingernägeln ablagern
dieses verfahren der isotopenanalyse hat
sich in den vergangenen jahren immer
weiter durchgesetzt
es wird mittlerweile sehr häufig von
fachleuten aus der forensik der
anthropologie und der archäologie
angewandt so kann man heute zum beispiel
sehr viel über das leben der
hafenarbeiter im alten rom erfahren
eine aktuelle studie eines britischen
forschungsteams konnte mit hilfe der
isotopenanalyse zeigen dass die
einfachen arbeiter mitte des er
jahrhunderts enorm von dem reichtum der
stadt profitiert haben müssen
sie ernährten sich von weizen fleisch
fisch und olivenöl aus dem
mittelmeerraum und ihr wein stammte aus
nordafrika obwohl sie einfache leute
waren lebten sie also eigentlich ganz
gut ihre arbeit war hart sie hatten die
aufgabe schwere güter aus dem ausland zu
verladen denn der hafen von rom galt
lange als das tor zur mächtigsten stadt
der welt unter den waren die die
hafenarbeiter zu verladen hatten waren
unter anderem marmor nahrungsmittel
kunstgegenstände und wilde tiere für die
shows im kolosseum die isotopenanalyse
der britischen fachleute zeigt ganz klar
dass sich die ernährung der einfachen
arbeiter am hafen kaum von der ernährung
der wohlhabenden menschen unterschied
die auf dem friedhof von isola sacra
begraben worden waren
dazu die archäologen und chemikerin
tamsin o'connell von der universität
cambridge soziale unterschiede zwischen
arbeitern und reichen bürgern können wir
anhand der begräbnis situation erkennen
die arbeiter ernährten sich genauso wie
die wohlhabende menschen damals sehr
hochwertig auch tierische produkte waren
dabei im detail waren es isotopenanalyse
von stickstoff und kohlenstoff aus dem
zahnschmelz und dem kollagen der knochen
von individuen aus verschiedenen
jahrhunderten die dem forschungsteam
diese details verrieten ernährten sich
die menschen damals von sogenannten c3
pflanzen wie hafer roggen reis oder
weizen ist dies noch heute gut im signal
zu unterscheiden von pflanzen wie mais
amaranth hirse oder zuckerrohr letztere
gelten als c4 pflanzen
der clou die verschiedenen isotope eines
elements weisen unterschiedliche massen
auf je nach umgebung und ernährung
reichen sich die schweren und leichten
isotope dann im menschlichen körper an
ihr verhältnis zueinander ist
entscheidend und natürlich messbar
die analysen im sogenannten
massenspektrometer und der vergleich mit
standardwerten liefert den forschenden
dann die ersten hinweise lassen die
menschen damals hauptsächlich pflanzen
oder auch tiere und fische die analyse
der stickstoff werte gibt dann noch
deutliche antworten auf diese fragen
denn diese zeigen die position in der
nahrungskette an fische und andere
lebewesen aus dem meer weisen den
höchsten stickstoff werte auf in
lebewesen die fleisch fressen werden
höhere werte gemessen als in reinen
pflanzenfressern letztendlich
vergleichen expertinnen und experten
dann
auch noch die werte von menschen die an
verschiedenen orten gelebt haben solche
analysen verraten das schicksal des
römischen hafens überraschender weise
sehr detailliert der wohlstand der stadt
ließ nach das zeigen die isotopenanalyse
der arbeiter ab dem fünften jahrhundert
hier zeigen die messung dass sich die
kohlenstoff und stickstoff werden
schlagartig veränderte die hafenarbeiter
aßen plötzlich nur noch gemüse und
einfache eintöpfe aus bohnen und linsen
die umstände in der stadt führten dazu
dass sie sich mit einfachen bauern essen
zufrieden geben mussten das essen der
wohlhabenden bürgern dagegen blieb
zunächst noch ziemlich reichhaltig
zumindest für einige zeit aus grabungen
bestätigten tatsächlich diesen wandel
das hafenbecken versandete und die
anzahl der einwohner roms lang und es
traf die stadt noch schlimmer im jahr
455 nach christus wurden der hafen und
die stadt durch vandalen zerstört und
eingenommen dazu die expertin tamsin
o'connell als ruhmreich war war jeder
von der lokalen eliten bis zu den
hafenarbeitern gut ernährt dann kommt
dieser große politische bruch und
zumindest den handarbeiten gibt es nicht
mehr so gut wie früher
geisteswissenschaftliche fragen wie
beispielsweise nach der hierarchie
bestimmter kulturen können so mit
naturwissenschaftlichen methoden
beantwortet werden so auch bei den
überresten aus dem keltischen gräberfeld
in der nähe von bern aus den fünften bis
dritten jahrhundert die isotopen analyse
zeigte dass sich die menschen damals
offensichtlich zum großteil von c3
pflanzen ernährt haben
höchstwahrscheinlich handelte es sich um
getreide
doch das verfahren offenbarte dass die
männer im vergleich zu den frauen damals
viel mehr fleisch zu sich genommen haben
müssen dazu sandra rösch von der
universität bern fleisch war individuen
in höheren sozialen stellungen
vorbehalten
genau diese männer mit den hohen
stickstoff isotopenverhältnisse bahn im
grab mit waffen ausgestattet auch das
ein hinweis auf einen höheren sozialen
status das besondere hierbei die
isotopen daten verraten uns wie die
sozialen strukturen von damals
ausgesehen haben könnten und das obwohl
schriftliche quellen fehlen wahnsinn
klar ist auch dass diese technik ihre
grenzen hat als ergebnis liefert sie
keineswegs absolute werte die sofort
einer bestimmten zeit region und einem
ernährungs profil zuzuordnen sind
wichtig sind vergleichsdaten und
natürlich eine ausreichende menge an
daten ansonsten ist der interpretation
nicht aussage
kräftig doch vor allem in kombination
mit archäologischen informationen lassen
sich wichtige hinweise durch die
isotopenanalyse gewinnen dabei ist klar
dass die erhebung und interpretation der
daten immer komplizierter wird je weiter
man in der zeit zurückreist und so ist
auch die frage um die ernährung der
neandertaler weiterhin offen
forschungsteams weltweit diskutieren
kontrovers darüber ob diese nur fleisch
aßen oder sich auch mit gemüse und fisch
ernährt haben was sind isotope anklicken
anschauen und musste wissen schien nie
abonnieren auch sehr cooler kanal von
funk bis dann bleibt dran